hi everyone today I'm with my friend
David again David Gaza runs his own
YouTube channel which I'll look down
below and we thought today we would like
to talk to you about some of the books
we recommend for learning physics so
this is a question I've had reasonably
often which is how do I either go from
nothing to knowing something about
physics and how do I find books to do
that so I thought David having done
physics yourself and now you're working
in physics you'd have a good perspective
on that yeah so I thought a good one to
start off with for these would be for
those of you who are looking at this
recreationally or you want to get the
very first idea of what's involved in a
certain topic and for those I can
recommend a series of books called very
short introductions you can get a very
short introduction to nuclear physics a
very short introduction to particle
physics or quantum mechanics and they do
those for lots of different subjects you
can get a very short introduction to
business management and Islam and
anything any sort of studies you want
they have over 400 of these books
they're very very small you can read
them in a few hours you can pick them up
for about $13 if you get the Kindle
version there's a little as seven on
nine dollars so they don't give you any
of the maths of the physics but they
give you a very brief overview of the
concepts where the science is today so
if you're doing cosmology it'll talk
about Big Bang nucleosynthesis evolution
of the universe how we got to where we
are I don't know any physics at the
moment like it's not any required
background yeah if you don't have any
background in physics yet these are good
books to get you started or get you
interested or just for recreational
reading I'll make sure like everything
we're about to say is linked down below
like in the description and I'll put
like little pictures of the covers
so what else do you think is good for
total beginners in a way for total
beginners I know you're a fan of Marcus
Chan I'm a fan of market town - that's
one of my favorites so um I guess in
high school was when I started reading
Marcus Chan books and he writes popular
science or popular physics books and I
thought you didn't really need any
background in physics to understand them
but they were really interesting so one
in particular which was recommended to
me by a friend in high school was we
need to talk about Kelvin and it's got
like really good descriptions of like
stellar nucleosynthesis and how stars
work and just how astronomy works in a
way I found that really interesting yeah
I've read several of Marcus challenge
books they're real they're all really
really good there's a reason he's one of
the most popular science writers I was
one of my other favorite like pop
science writers that I read in high
school was this book at the edge of
physics by the author Anil and that's
something like that I'll put a picture
of it but it was all about I have heard
of the guy I know he's I haven't read
this one but I know the guys good well
the age of physics was all about
introducing you to things like these big
neutrino telescopes which they have an
Antarctica as well as like in old
abandoned gold mines it's like science
experiments but on the edge of science
like really awesome setups and things
you're like well I didn't know that
existed
sounds good I want to read that word
what else so we've got basically richard
fineman
so richard fineman for those of you
don't know him he's generally regarded
as one of the greatest physicists of all
time
he's probably in every physicists top
five top ten list yeah
he's famous for being able to explain
physics concepts and very difficult
physics concepts in very accessible ways
and so he's got several books there's
QED by Richard Feynman which is about
quantum electrodynamics which is his
field that he won the Nobel Prize for
but the famous thing is the Fineman
lectures on physics
now there's the final lectures on
physics are a bit funny they are in some
regards some of the best lectures on
physics ever and in some regards some of
the worst because firemen had always
previously taught postgraduate
physicists and he was asked to give
first and second year lectures and it
turned out that more post grads and more
professors turned out to these lectures
than the actual undergraduates he was
meant to be lecturing and he even says
in the introduction to these lectures in
the published version that he realizes
he didn't quite hit the mark with these
that if you're trying to pass an exam
these are not good lectures but if you
just want if you just want to learn
about the physics learn about the
concepts they are very good I think
Fineman is a really good communicator so
whilst I've never used the Fineman
lectures to study for something I have
read them out of interest and they're
actually what I would now go to to
understand deeply a concept yeah not
just to be able to do the equations on
the exams I don't think there's a lot of
math really in these prime electors it's
very conceptual and yeah he was one of
those guys that can just write on the
whiteboard and and take you on a journey
through the ideas yeah so a lot of my
lecturers based their lectures on the
Fineman lectures but then did it in a
different way so they would use Fineman
to work out what concepts and what
important things you need to get across
but then they would do it a different
way so that I could learn the maths and
pass the exam so for people who are
looking to get into this as a first step
so reading for recreation or you're a
high school student wondering what's
what what our future holds in physics if
you continue studying physics fineman's
really really good and even an
undergraduate level because these
deficiencies and the fireman lectures
have been recognised you can get course
readers to go along with the fireman
lectures so you can read the lecture and
then go
problem sets and so overall I think that
balances out I don't remember if we said
but like the Fineman lectures are all
available online as well as like yeah
but I think Caltech put them all online
in in written form there's also like
like you said some companion arenas
online but yeah you can you can find
links to those ones yeah Feynman also
has like other books as well like surely
you're joking mr. Fineman and he has a
few books on like problem solving those
are not necessarily to learn physics but
you might find them interesting they're
great stories but there's not a lot of
physics in surely you're joking
you wanted to mention Michio Kaku now I
haven't read any Michiyo cupcake I've
seen his TV stuff yeah well to be honest
I've seen more of Moschino like TV stuff
then I have his books but I remember one
of the books I had in high school of his
was parallel worlds and again I get I
don't think you're really learning
physics from this but it's like a really
awesome overview of like cosmology in
the future of the universe in a way it's
quite a grand scale it was an
interesting now let's talk about this
nice stack of textbooks we have no waves
from undergrad and all the fun stuff so
for undergraduate I my textbook in
undergraduate was fundamentals of
physics by Halliday Resnick and Walker
what was yours so my first year physics
textbook was by serwe in Jewett and it
was physics for scientists and engineers
now I think it was an OK book it it was
for like engineers as well it was quite
applied but it took you through
everything you needed to know to pass
their seeit physics I thought it was
fine I went back to my first year one in
later years the Halliday Resnick Walker
one was written really well it's on its
millionth edition my mum used it back
when she was studying at university so
it's gone through it's been used again
and again and again
updated year after year I think it's
very very good the explanations and the
maths and the worked problems in it but
so many of so many of these are good
there's Jun Kolya as well I really think
that any introductory or first-year you
need
spoke on calculus or physics it's gonna
be pretty much the same there's only so
many ways you can talk about the
fundamental physics concepts like
mechanics a little bit of modern physics
thermodynamics there's only so many ways
you can introduce those topics so I
think just pick up any first-year
textbook you should be fine I think
actually my Segway and your textbook was
the only one I actually bought in the
university I was like oh I'm at uni I
need to buy the textbooks I bought it
for the first semester and then after
that I would download the PDF we'll just
get it out from the library so it's not
necessary to to buy all these textbooks
there's other ways to get them okay so
I'm moving on beyond first year second
year third year you're learning special
relativity quantum mechanics more
complex atomic physics for me this was
my Bible this is modern physics by
Tipler and Llewellyn there are lots of
books called modern physics everything
that you can find books called modern
physics from a hundred years ago it's
not the best title but for some reason
they persist with it but this was really
really good
it covers all those sorts of things from
relativity to cosmology wave-like
properties of particles Schrodinger
equation
quantum mechanics molecular structure I
think anything that's not Newton
mechanics is class modern physics yeah
yeah pretty much there's a like like
postmodern so other thing there's
anything what things that 1920s first of
all the worked examples in this really
really good so even if you are actually
a recreational reader and you want to
learn how how to calculate that e equals
mc-squared or you want to understand the
Schrodinger equation on a some
mathematical level this is actually
pretty good it leads you slowly and
methodically through those calculations
and so I would come back to this book
year after year to relearn the stuff I'd
forgotten or get the first bits even
later courses like in honors I would go
to this to get the first bits of the
course and then build
from there so I highly recommend this
book it was wonderful it got me through
my undergrad alright thanks for that one
I can see the next one on this list
because one of my ones
this is Charles cattell and this is
introduction to solid state physics now
Cattell also has a book which is I think
an introduction to thermal physics and
both of those I found really good now in
a way I think when you're at university
the best textbook to be getting and
reading is the one that you think your
lecturer is reading and taking the
problems from for the exam in which case
from most exams on solar state physics
I've ever done the cushions have come
from this book cattell so I just found
it to be really easy to understand to
read the problems were easy to do and
the problems often showed up in
assignments in exams so I would
recommend anything by cattell I haven't
read it all but it sounds good
right now we're on to David Griffiths so
Toby and I are both fans of David
Griffiths we both have heard from other
people who really don't like David
Griffiths but Toby and I did our degrees
in different countries we're both huge
fans of David Griffiths I had David
Griffiths books assigned as course
readers in undergrad most of the people
I went through physics with really
really liking there are some people who
don't I think they're crazy because
David Griffiths is a really really good
writer of textbooks so we've got a
couple of his here so the one on top
just happens to be introduction to
elementary particles so quarks and
gluons and things and all that subatomic
physics it's DJ Griffiths he's a really
really good writer my undergraduate
courses were basically built around
these books I learnt a lot they're very
very clear you can follow through the
exercises and the maths very very easily
I think DJ Griffiths is really really
good so here we've got introduction to
elementary particles we've also got his
introduction to electrodynamics
I think it's considered one of the
greatest physics textbooks of all time
we're going to talk about this one later
this is like a post-grad electrodynamics
book when I was doing this course I had
to check out that book as well just to
decipher what was in here so that one
saved me a few times yeah my favorite
griffiths book is his introduction to
quantum mechanics it's just the cutest
book it's got this cover with a cat
alive on one side and dude on the back
yep and I would just always want to have
that book checked out with me because it
was just if I had a problem with quantum
mechanics I don't know I thought that
that book could answer for me at least
in the undergrad since like I've heard
the criticism of that particular intro
to quantum that it doesn't cover
anything you know higher level or post
grad level quantum but you don't need
that you're doing undergrad so that was
fine yeah so for quantum mechanics
electrodynamics and subatomic physics
particle physics
Ddraig Griffith books we highly
recommend he's also got another book
which is called where have I written at
revolutions in 20th century physics no I
haven't read that one but I've had a
quick flip through it and it seems to be
very similar to my modern physics by
Tipler and Llewellyn so it covers
relativity and atomic physics and wave
particle duality and things like that at
a slightly lower level so again it's
probably good if you're looking to first
get into those sort of Sciences or if
you're looking for a Bible will get you
through your undergrad it seems like
Griffiths revolutions in 20th century
physics is a very good book
yeah good author so we agree on that one
I've had it recommended to me by others
but I haven't read that one specifically
so were there any more undergrad books
that you had on your little list nope so
we've gone through all the undergrad
ones now we're on to the post okay I
mentioned this on earlier this was um my
number one most hated book but I see I
did a course I suppose during my honours
year in physics and we did like
electromag and it was just I found this
particular book quite hard to understand
we
use it as part of the course our
assignment questions were questions from
here but I personally found this book
really hard to read I don't know what
your book tire I had that same book
assigned as well if talking to other
physicists looking around online it is
generally considered the best
postgraduate electrodynamics textbook
it's like the most advanced I think than
the other textbooks and that's why it
has that reputation because it's like
it's it's a lot more advanced than the
other electric like you I needed to go
back to Griffiths
- then let's springboard into that so I
can do that back yeah and again there
are cut to help you with that there are
course readers and worked problems that
small sorts of other problems online so
in terms of passing exams we highly
recommend this book in terms of wanting
to read it okay right so the weird stuff
things like quantum gravity string
theory I have for quantum gravity I'm
not sure about recommending this this is
quantum gravity by carlo rovelli carlo
rovelli is a theorist who specializes in
loop quantum gravity
he writes beautifully his maths and his
language is really easy to follow he
writes absolutely beautifully he even
throws in sort of bits of other art and
culture he's a very wide read guy so
they'll be references to Hamlet and
other things in this book it really is
fantastic
the problem with recommending carlo
rovelli is talking to I'm not a theorist
I'm an experimentalist so talking to the
theorists I know they're not so big fans
of his because he is loop quantum
gravity and
I when I was doing my undergrad I
thought Luke quantum gravity was sort of
not really taken seriously anymore that
it was started dying about 20 years ago
Ravel he's still working in that field
if you read his stuff then you start
coming around to the loop quantum
gravity way of thinking and you start to
think this is a serious contender this
is really really good there's a lot of
potential here while the theorists I
talked to back at my old institution
would take now it so quantum gravity
this is brilliantly written easy to
follow whether it will take you further
than post graduate not sure okay and
string theory is when we had a problem
with I guess I didn't have a good I
didn't have a good book to recommend for
this one either
I asked friends for recommendations who
knew more about string theory than I did
and the recommendation was that there is
no good textbook for string theory I was
told there's one good one but you need
to go and get a separate differential
geometry textbook in order to be able to
go to the differential geometry one
learn from that and then come back to so
basically if you're looking at string
theory at the postgraduate level you
don't need our help yes please yes I
guess those are some of the textbooks
those are what we think are good and
what have helped us get to where we are
I would say like as we're wrapping up if
you are like trying to learn some
physics teach yourself physics go to
books but also don't discount online
resources whether you're starting at
something like Khan Academy to just get
the first skills all the way up to like
there are Fineman lectures online like
recordings there are all sorts of things
on YouTube as well that you can actually
learn a lot of good physics from yeah
MIT and Caltech and a lot of other
universities put their courses online
there's a theoretical physicist Jared T
Hooft who has put a started compiling
online a list of free online resources
for people who want to get into physics
C's put it out in special relativity
general relative
the string theory things like that the
list isn't complete yet some of it like
you click on string theory and
supergravity and it's just three dots
it's just empty because he hasn't
finished compiling it yet but they're
all online free resources that he
recommends for you to go and learn about
these things so there are more than
buying expensive borders and also I
think with this advice if you want to
learn more physics just read the books
and consume the content that you
actually enjoy reading and learning
about don't force yourself to sit
through a textbook you find really
really awful unless you need to for a
course just like yeah don't do any sort
of learning that you enjoy alright I
think that's all our advice thanks David
thanks for having me thanks for watching